hello folks how's everybody doing
hope you're doing fine we have another
glorious extinction day today so if you
don't want to get your mood down well
stick around you might learn something
okay anyways I'm gonna start directly
I'm gonna jump in directly with a couple
comments that were made and that sets
the tone for what I'm going to be
discussing today so here it goes the
first one and this all says we can
provide essential staple food for all at
a fraction of the average workers
current take-home pay which would not
require unsustainable taxation or
hyperinflation what is he referring to
he is referring to my theory that says
that humans will become extinct when
food is no more food is no more when the
economy collapses meaning that trade
will be no more in other words money
will no longer have any value that's
what I was that's the theory and this is
what his reply is okay he's gonna
analyze this paying other costs like
rent mortgages etc is a bigger challenge
it's more likely we'll see mass
homelessness loss of transport heating
etc before masturbation's in the
aftermath of this pandemic though food
distribution and processing could be an
issue and he followed that up with
another set of comments here farmers
always have an incentive to grow food
for future income because some form of
payment will be a value in the future
even if some currency is devalued they
would seek government assistance if
necessary to do this and governments
will prioritize support if there is a
shortage of farm workers governments
would introduce short-term incentives to
make farm work worthwhile in the medium
long term more farm work is going to be
automated making food production cheaper
okay the true cost of a resource
reflects
human effort required to produce it
which for food is not going to increase
unsustainable farming practices should
gradually self-correct trend to organic
new sustainable methods as the cost of
unsustainable practice will start to
rise okay no mention of the dinosaurs
there that had struck me a little bit
you know you would think this fellow
would have mentioned something about the
permian synapses or the dinosaurs or
someone for Cretaceous dinosaurs no
mention of that he just went in there
and talked about humans and I would get
the same situation with another set of
comments here couple comments here and
this fall says the fact that we live in
a service-based society means more of us
can live substantially better lives
versus his Paleolithic ancestors
assuming mine and says we certainly live
longer lives yes and that's one of the
signs that were ready for extinction
when we live longer lives and I've
covered that in the past I won't go into
that in any depth today at least in fact
the service sector is the largest sector
in the world even bill acknowledges this
yes absolutely and that's that's the
problem a virus pandemic especially of
this magnitude will be all but forgotten
in five to ten years from now let us
hope cross our fingers right hope to die
yeah the the problem there is that the
service sector I've already covered that
I'll just briefly put the graph that
gives you puts it in the proper context
okay and here's the context the context
is that we were hunter-gatherers for
more than a hundred thousand years ten
thousand years we did farming when we
domesticated both plants and animals for
the last two hundred years maybe three
hundred years we were in a manufacturing
revolution Industrial Revolution and I
think it was 1979 when we switched when
when services took over
and became the dominant mode of
production displacing both manufacturing
and farming
not to mention hunter-gathering so yeah
as you can see the timelines are
decreasing it's an exponential process
and the question is what comes after
services I mean if we have a service
economy now are we gonna be doing
services for the next million years are
we gonna have like I say more Baker's
and fewer farmer and fewer bankers one
year and I don't know more waitress
waitresses and fewer cashiers another
year is that what we're going to be
doing we're just gonna be putting people
in different categories of services for
the next million years and no services
first it's the last mode of the human
economy there is nothing coming after
service as you can imagine because we've
done it all from manufacturing to
services agriculture we've done it all
and the other problem is services is
unemployment services is mass
unemployment and I showed the example
the other day where what do we have now
30 million people unemployed in the
United States they went to the
unemployment office to ask for help from
the government and we didn't even notice
it
why didn't we didn't we didn't notice it
because a lot of those were worker hotel
workers restaurant workers maybe airline
employees and so on and we don't need
that we don't need any of those services
those are luxuries tourism is luxury and
you know I give the example of God
looking down from heaven you know at the
earth and what does he see he sees what
we built what is real well he sees the
buildings the skyscrapers the you know
the streets the highways he sees also
the farming stuff you know he sees the
all the what is it all the fields
cornfields wheat fields rice fields he
sees all that what he doesn't see is
services he doesn't see banking he
doesn't see insurance he doesn't see any
of that he doesn't see entertainment all
that is is unnecessary so we live in a
luxury economy we live in an unnecessary
economy and yeah we unfortunately most
of our economy today is services that is
the problem services is another way of
saying unemployment so how much services
can contribute to the economy well I
don't know they don't produce anything
per se what we produce is through
services we make manufacturing and
agriculture run that's how it works ok
and services per se doesn't produce
anything it's just promises you know
what is it insurance policy to promise
there's nothing there you know and
that's why I call all these people
Disneyland economist you know they they
follow Milton Friedman and
Adam Smith you know everyone pursuing
his own self-interest pushes the world
look forward yeah only only if you have
a job and when you don't have a job well
then the government sends you a paycheck
like it did the other day and if it were
so easy I mean they should just continue
giving us paychecks right in fact I
would love the US government they give
everybody a million dollars imagine
everybody received a million dollars hey
we've got it made right we don't have to
worry about anything anymore do we
yeah why doesn't they do why don't they
do that well they don't do that because
there there's a cost just giving money
away as a cost and until people
understand that you know they don't
understand anything but what is my
objection to these fellows and by the
way most people I think think like them
okay so I'm in the minority and I
realize that but I'm gonna defend my
point and let me tell you over the the
issue the issue here is that these
people talk about extinction 102 and
they don't want to cover extinction
101c you need a prerequisite to talk
about extinction before you can talk
about extinction 102 you have to deal
with extinction 101 and you see what the
hell are you talking about bill what's
what's all this 101 102 stuff well you
know when you go to college you have
these 101 course in there prerequisites
of 102 and one tens and other courses
that come afterwards right and 101 is
like an introductory course and yeah
before you can talk about human
extinction extinction 102 you need to
talk about extinction which is the
extinction 101 you need to understand
the basics of extinction and I've got
all these experts on human economy
everybody's an expert on that because
everybody's an expert on their own
opinion and politics that's what
everybody does nobody wants to do
research and really figure out something
about extinction per se so you ask them
something about the Permian they don't
even know how to spell that word you
know and so they don't even know what
animals existed in those days what
plants existed and it's like you know
you saw how did they die well let me
look it up and they'll look it up and
they'll go to the bozos that come out of
Harvard and Cambridge universities and
those people have never figured it out
200 years no one has figured out
extinction not one single paleontologist
that's why I have very little respect
for any paleontologist on earth I have
very little respect for that whole
profession because a lot of people think
that a paleontologist is a person who
goes out into the field looks for bones
right into rock finds one dusts it off
gives it a fancy name assembles it puts
it in the museum and starts charging you
know start selling tickets now that's a
stamp collector that's not a palliative
paleontologist has only one job in one
job only when he figures that out
paleontology is no more we don't need
paleontology anymore a paleontologist is
tasked with discovering how the animals
in the past died how they became extinct
that's his only purpose in life
once we figure that out we don't need
paleontology anymore okay so all this
stuff about collecting bones and dusting
them giving them fancy day that's that's
stamp collecting okay and all we have
today on planet earth are stamp
collectors we have no paleontologists
okay now you know where I'm coming from
on this okay so why don't we start with
a little picture a big picture of what
happened in the past I'm gonna cover
extinction 101 I want to know how the
animals in the past died before I can
talk about man and what's the what's the
logic here the logic is that you know if
I can figure out how animals died in the
past maybe I can figure out that there's
a cookie cutter that you know it's a
repeatable process and that all of these
animals died in the same way and if
that's the case we can extrapolate that
mechanism to humans okay we extrapolated
to humans and find out if man can avoid
that same mechanism okay you get my
logic here my reasoning and so when you
go into the past well what I find is
that animals died all in the same way
mass extinctions and also background
extinction so there's two forms of
extinctions that Mother Nature has
background which is when a single
species dies and a mass extinction when
many species usually family or an order
goes away and Mother Nature has only two
mechanism one for mass extinction one
for background extinction and that's how
what you find in the record in the
literature what you find in the
literature is ad hoc mechanism do you
find one mechanism per species so if
it's in the air well who knows what
happened to them maybe brick fire and
brimstone rained down them now you know
or maybe they ran out of air maybe the
carbon and nitrogen cycle somehow
affected the bird
how about the ones in the sea well there
was acid rain and it fell in it poisoned
the waters some died and some lived
competition how about those on land well
who knows maybe it was an asteroid maybe
it was volcano volcano volcanic activity
maybe it was a supernova so they have
all these different theories to expand
specially the catastrophic events why
something happened so suddenly as
recorded you know in the rock layer and
so they have to come up with
catastrophic theories because they never
thought of anything else okay well
that's what I'm gonna do bunk I'm gonna
show that no mother nature's a simple
lady okay very simple lady she does
things very simply and it's all very
natural we don't have catastrophic
accidents it involved in any mass
extinction that's what I'm gonna argue
today okay so let's go with extinction
101 let's see here we have a little
snapshot of certain relations we had
certain types of plants in different
eras okay and for each plant you had
certain types of animals here I start at
the Carboniferous and what you see there
the first one on the left is a an
amphibian from there we went to these
weird animals that had sailed back this
was a typhus aureus there and they ate
something different than the ones in the
Carboniferous because the plants changed
in great measure well the plants kept
changing and the animals kept changing
for some reason you have the next time
pariah Tsar that's the guy that's gonna
finish off the Permian and there's a
certain type of plant that was very
abundant in those days and also
disappeared at the end of the Permian
just by sheer coincidence and again I'm
only looking at the land animals here
then you can have the age of the
Triassic the arcus ours
they were crocodile like animals that
could move a little faster on land
then crocodiles can today and and ever
tied to certain plants then we had you
know the Jurassic the big long necks are
very famous for that period different
type of plant altogether
Cretaceous same thing we had the
conifers were under way out and when the
young econ occurs were on their way out
we came along the last one there and the
grasses came into being and today 87% of
what we produce or eat is our grasses
including and that also feeds the same
mammals that we eat ok so that's a
snapshot you can see that animals to
some degree are related to certain types
of plants if you name a certain type of
planet in the past for sure you're gonna
have certain types of animals associated
with that and not others ok so somehow
animals and plants go together and that
should not surprise you because when a
plant certain certain types of plants
evolve and expand throughout the
landscape and they form like the
majority of plants or the animals that
are gonna carve niches in in those
plants you know they're gonna they have
nothing else to eat so they have to do
that and so one animal eats this plan
another one eats that plan over there
and they form these dynasties and they
evolve the plant evolves they evolve and
over the millions of years you have
these new these new species evolved and
at some point those plants have to go
out they have their cycle and people are
not aware of that yeah they say no
plants continue forever well you just
saw that plants did not continue forever
and the question is why I mean why don't
we still have a cooksonia
plant that just came out of the water
way up there in the millions of years
ago and uh you know cuckoo song is not
around today except in the rock you can
see it there maybe you see other plants
that came after also in the carbon
in the permian and they no longer exist
and so we have their fossil records
there now no longer around you say well
what happened to them why didn't why
don't they well I don't these plants
still exist today if plants them forever
and yeah what people fail to see is
plants have their population curve as
well long-term population curve and then
they die they become old they die what
does old mean it means that after
millions of years of inbreeding they
finally lose genetic diversity and at
some point they become numerous old and
then they die in mass and when they die
in mass all those animals had forge
relationships with those plants they go
with them and this is another thing
people don't understand they say well
the animal will start eating something
else so he was eating I don't know seed
ferns well the UH the animal says well
there are no more seed ferns around I
think I'm gonna start eating conifers or
maybe I'll eat the grasses or whatever's
out there it doesn't work that way first
of all they don't have their stomachs
ready for that new plant it's poison for
them just like for you eating ferns no
one eats ferns no mammal eats ferns I
mean there might be you I think there's
one exception out there a couple that
develop found a way of eating it but you
know mammals in general don't need ferns
because it's poisonous for us it's you
know it doesn't do any good it's like
eating weeds
do you eat weeds and those are
angiosperms so the only ways much lesser
you're gonna eat you know ferns or
conifers for that man we don't need
Christmas trees leaves you know we don't
eat those I mean I don't at least I
don't know about you so no animals no
don't just switch overnight and say you
know the rabbits eating lettuce and says
tomorrow and I think I'm going to start
eating pine leaves no it doesn't work
that way
okay plants are not plants are not
plants there are plants and there are
plants okay and animals are smarter than
humans they know the difference they
know what they like they know what they
don't like and even if they can eat
something else it
usually makes them sick or kills them so
they have to be very careful as well on
that side they've got every animal as
his food the food he likes the most okay
they can't switch overnight because
suddenly certain plants are missing okay
so let's go before that well let me just
cover this I want to show a big picture
also what happened in the seas I'm gonna
cover the seas today but I just want to
show the big picture okay so did you get
a feel for why food is important okay
and here you have it okay this is this
is a map that I made okay and it shows
that we had really three big regions
okay and those or eras you can say in
time regions in time and I called the
age of trilobite the age of ammonites
and the age of krill today in this day
and age we live in the age of krill you
could say what am I saying here well you
have the plankton and these animals are
kind of like the middleman you know
they're the small animals and they take
care of the plankton and then other
animals eat the trilobite the ammonites
or the crow that's how it works oh so
these are pretty good markers for
different layers of rock how many
troglobites or where the trilobite swirl
how they evolve over time we have quite
a bit of information on these animals
and as you can see in the case of
troglobites you know there were many
species and many families many orders of
trilobite you know Tyler White's not a
trilobite us at a trilobite there are
trial rights and there are others there
are trilobite they're different okay and
each one of those figures that are
pointing outward shows you approximately
when these different orders of prior
bites appeared and how they disappeared
and you can see on the bottom graph in
pink there how they dwindled over time
and eventually they ended up becoming
extinct exactly at the permian-triassic
boundary okay coincidence
well that's where many of the sea
creatures died at the end of the Permian
okay so it wasn't only land animals it
was also in the seas and yeah you can
see not only that the numbers decrease
but you can also see that the number of
species or the orders came down we ended
up with only one order in the end that
lasted until the Permian that was it for
all the trial of whites same story for
the age of ammonites the ammonites you
know they started in the Devonian but
they really became prominent in the
Jurassic in the in the Mesozoic and what
happened there well what happened was
you had different species different
families also and towards the end there
I showed just a couple numbers in the
last 30 million years they went from 19
families to 11 to finally to only two
families finished you know the the race
very similar to the trilobite and what
am I saying I'm saying that well you
can't produce these kinds of graphs with
asteroids and or with volcanoes and this
is the problem the problem is that you
see the graphs there people are aware of
it in paleontology but it's like they
don't pay attention to them and they
start looking for ridiculous theories to
try to explain you know the
disappearance of these animals when it's
very clear that they're disappearing
gradually over millions of years and the
age of krill which is our age now they
started also around 130 million years
ago that's the best estimate they have
but they became prominent after the
collapse of the cake at the KT boundary
that's when they started to expand and
to this day you know krill is that
middleman that serves between the
plankton and bigger animals and in the
last 30 years we had a 70% decline so
that gives you an idea in in the
population of krill and so that gives
you an idea that we've got a little bit
of a problem that we're facing in the
seas today because the
very indicative of a of a mass
extinction in the in progress and again
30 years is nothing from a geological
standpoint okay so that just gives you a
picture what happened in the seas a very
general picture and you know you should
ponder that you know if the pattern is
there and it's got to do with food it
doesn't have anything to do with
asteroids volcanoes you know the trial
of the the krill there they're
disappearing before our very eyes and no
one knows why they they have this well
it's the climate that's what that's what
else are the what is a what else is the
paleontologists gonna say he doesn't
know any better
so he's got says the climate like this
thought I talked the other day guy guy
McPherson yeah it's the climate they
think it's the climate no it's the crow
has had its its cycle and that's time
for krill to die krill is an old species
it's been around for 130 million years
if we look at the numbers that they
speculated on and if we accept those
numbers that's an old species old type
of animal right even though there's many
species many families and it's on its
way out it's just that simple and when
it's on its way out
you know what's gonna replace it well
the first problem is that plankton is
also on its way out there's a lot of
flankton out there die animals it's on
that are having problems today the krill
are having problems and guess what
that's the bottom of the food chain for
the seas okay
keep that in mind oh that's all I can
tell you it's got something to do with
food whatever anyone else tells you okay
so what is my my proposal I'm saying
well you know the biblical story here's
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse and
I'm gonna say that third horse from the
left the Black Horse famine that's the
guy that's going to do it and this is
what he looks like when he comes around
it's not it's not gonna be any of the
others uh which is war and death and
pestilence nuts this guy it's the
guy who carries the balance okay because
you had to yeah you had to put the scale
you had to put things on the scale to
weigh things to trade and so yeah it's
the horsemen black horsemen the guy
that's the starvation because he's he's
gonna essentially the reason he's
carrying the scallions that's where you
put food and gold and so on to you know
to make the trade okay and so that's the
symbol for starvation and yeah I think
it's gonna be the third Horseman that's
gonna kill us it's not gonna be war no
war if anything helps you know just adds
but no it's going to be starvation
because we're not gonna produce food or
distribute it and right now we all
depend on someone else producing the
food and distributing it to us see that
wasn't the case in the upper
Palaeolithic where you had you know
everybody doing his own thing the clans
went out there hunted something that was
on the plains you know maybe they hunted
you know Mastodon or a mammoth or
whatever or some other animal and they
brought it to the cave they slaughtered
and they all ate and they lived another
day that's or a couple days at least
and so that's the way it was in those
days they were in direct contact with
the food supply that's one issue the
other issues they were in the Eden
they were in Eden because there they
couldn't hunt all the animals that were
available there were too many animals
available pound wise right compared to
the number of people that lived upon
them so then it's like the the American
Indians like the Sioux you know they had
all these buffalos they could kill well
there were a million buffalos and these
guys were a few thousand and so they
didn't they had no chance of killing
millions of buffalos okay they had no
chance whatsoever so they would go out
there hunt one kill him eat and they
would continue living on and on and on
because the supply was essentially
infinite as far as they were concerned
they had all these Buffalo they could
hunt one any time they wanted we don't
have that situation here we live day to
day
mouth to mouth you
no we don't we don't store food for
seven years like the biblical pharaohs
did allegedly you know storing grain and
so on we don't store grain for seven
years
hey now what we do is we produce food
upon demand you know you got a
restaurant you don't have to wait seven
years now they bring you the food within
minutes at least in most restaurants
maybe not in McDonald's or earlier okay
and so yeah it takes a that we don't we
don't store food for years okay we don't
have supply of food for eight billion
people for the next seven or ten years
no way and so yeah once we stopped
producing food shuts down like today
that's it you know it's not like you're
gonna get some more unless someone plant
something and distributes it so keep
that in mind that's not the case with
the Paleolithic people because you know
they had ample supply of food
essentially infinite meat there yeah and
by the way those Spears they weren't
used to hunt lettuce or tomatoes or pool
apples from the trees now they hunted
yeah we were meat eaters okay I know
vegetarians don't like to hear that but
yeah we were meat eaters for most of our
existence and we just became vegetarians
to some degree maybe ten to fifteen
thousand years ago when we domesticated
plants okay so what's the mechanism I
proposed here it is the overturning of
the population of the ecological pyramid
the one on the left is a healthy one
where you have a few ten to one ratio
between primary production and to Hera
wars there's a ten to one ratio there
and there's a ten to one ratio between
herbivores and predators that would be
an ideal pyramid and what happens in a
mass extinction that pyramid gets
overturned you got little primary
production the hair Brewers are starving
and they preyed upon by a bunch of
predators who so lose their source of
food because they liquidate everything
in sight
okay so this is the mechanism I'm
proposing and so let's look at what
happened in the past let's look at one
era at a time when when period one time
period of time here's a Carboniferous
and you get an idea I'm just gonna give
some ideas I can't cover all the details
of all the animals that existed okay
just give you some examples to show you
that you got to pay attention to food or
at least ponder it or factor it in your
analysis of extinction at least
extinction 101 of the animals in the
past okay here's the first one and this
is the Carboniferous there was a what is
known as the rainforests collapse 305
million years ago and these are the
comments they come out of the Wikipedia
but this comes out of the literature
okay so it's it's got Authority you
could say not that we trust Authority
but this is I think a pretty good idea
of what they see in the rock suddenly a
bunch of animals a bunch of plants
disappeared okay and said this event may
have fragmented the forests into
isolated islands which in turn caused
dwarfism and shortly after extinction of
many plant and animal species okay just
because of the rainforest collapse a
major abrupt extinction of the dominant
like like capsids any change to tree
fern dominated ecosystems in other words
the ferns began to replace the club
mosses like like copses our club mosses
or mosses of different times and so the
point here is that we had a change in
vegetation and all those animals that
depended on the club mosses suddenly you
know had trouble and they were gradually
or relatively quickly because there was
a fine a quick line between the
carboniferous and permian that we can
distinguish in the rock we can see
something happened there and what
happened was that the plants and animals
aged okay and if plants and animals
change why would you think that's the
case
perhaps the food went away and the
animals went away the animals who
developed a long-term relationship with
those plants and here this is before the
collapse animal species distribution was
very cosmopolitan the same species
existed everywhere across tropical
Pangaea but after the collapse each
surviving rainforest Island develops
developed its own unique mix of species
many amphibian species became extinct
while the ancestors of reptiles and
mammals diversified into more species
after the initial crisis okay so yeah
new animals replace the old ones because
new plants replace the old ones okay at
least that's my conclusion you can reach
your own conclusion but again I want you
to take into consideration that
transition in the plant world and
because of that in the animal world and
remember you know plants don't go off
you know in two seconds it takes a long
time for them to vanish
you know species wise and number wise
with you know population wise with
population wise within each species and
so something was happening and it was
happening gradually until it finally
reached a critical point where a lot of
animals began officially you know a lot
of these Vivien's could not find food
and suddenly they went extinct because
you know they had trouble eating
especially the herbivores around there
and you know the whole the whole
ecological system depended on those
herbivores eating the plants so the
whole food chain collapsed and another
food chain that dependant on different
kinds of plants you know they were in
effect they say what's going on we don't
know the big guys are getting out of
here and we're gonna take over and
that's exactly what happened
Midway into the Permian you get this
called Olsen's extinction okay and you
can see there's a difference between the
animals on the left and the ones on the
right and all these are considered
mammal-like reptiles but they're a
little different
okay the ones on the left are known as
synapsids okay the ones on the right
well you have with their absent there
and a pariah Tsar okay there are
different kinds of animals though guys
on the Left look more like reptiles if
you would think but see all these
animals laid eggs and they filled that
region of time called the Permian and it
says the following says plants showed
large turnover in the mid to late
permian and into the Triassic the
duration of higher extinction rates
greater than 60 percent in land plants
was about twenty-three point four
million years starting from Olsen's
extinction and into the early middle
triassic Olsen's extinction represents
the third highest peak of extinction
rates seen in plants throughout the
Paleozoic and the number of general fell
by twenty five percent the extinction
was particularly severe among free
spurring plants free sporting means that
you know those sporting plants like
ferns and so on that there's seed ferns
and also sport friends and other sport
plants as well and those were losing
ground against not only not only the
seed firms but against another type of
plant that was rising which were the
cycads and the ginkgoes okay and these
were können were gonna be part of the
conifer world ok gymnosperms ok so again
there was a turnover in plants and this
created a turnover in animals in the
middle of the Permian there was an
extinction there that they cannot
explain ok and I think we have an
explanation if you open your mind to it
ok but at least if you don't believe it
at least you should ponder it and factor
it in whenever you talk about extinction
ok what happened at the end of the
permian that was 273 million years
here's 252 million years ago okay and
this is one of the most popular plants
or types of plants that covered that
whole region you can see their South
America Africa part of Australia and
Antarctica and why do they know that
well they know that because they found
these glass out there dales all over
that green that dark green region okay
they found him in every one of those
continents and they were the southern
continents okay and so what happens
within that one of the most popular was
this tree light plant that you see on
the left that's called Glossop Terrace
and these were these plants almost
dominated completely the the landscape
in in that southern region was almost
the only plant that existed in other
words that not only plant but the the
order the type of plant that existed
this was almost all there it was so what
did the herbivores eat if not this and
what do you think would happen when this
plant disappeared well all those animals
at carb Nisha's within each part of that
plant you know the seed the fruit or the
head no fruit but in the leaves or
whatever they made from it you know the
the this type of plant supported a whole
will ecosystem and what do you think
would happen when it when there when
when all these of plants disappeared
this type of plant disappeared after the
animals forged million millions of years
relationship with them well you would
think that the animals would disappear
as well and I think that's what happened
here you says glossopteris is an extinct
order of seed ferns arose at the
beginning of the Permian sea tells you
the the numbers of when they found these
right on the continent of Gondwana but
became extinct before the end of the
Permian period 250 1.9 million years ago
and 252 so the Year allegedly when all
these animals went extinct so it just
matches quite perfectly glossopteris
dales they covered the landscape they
disappear
and suddenly by sheer coincidence the
animals on land disappear as well you
figure it out says these plants went on
to become a dominant part of the
southern flora through the rest of the
Permian okay so yeah I don't know you
you reach your own conclusions all I can
tell you is that after doing 20 years of
research that's my conclusion had
nothing to do with volcanoes which is
one of the primary proposals today the
other one is methane coming from the sea
beds just oozing out filling me I mean
they have these catastrophic theories so
complex that mother nature's is is
shocked now they have this methane just
covering the air turning into co2 just
too much co2 or too much methane and
also because of that losing out it
covers the you have to cover the whole
planet right and that stops sunlight you
know photosynthesis and then a lot of
plants dying so the animals die and and
so on and so forth and how did the ones
in the water die well who knows I mean
it may be the gas when it came out just
killed those who could not stand it or
you know it's a question of competition
that's all these people talk about
that's all they can think of and let me
tell you why because see each one of
these guys they have pet peeves and they
solicit funds you know to be able to
carry out their their studies their
research and so I can tell the case of
Paul Wignall a British guy who went to
Greenland I think it was and he goes
there and he looks at the methane that's
what he studies and sure enough you know
he gets this money to go there on a
vacation trip he does his study and he
comes back he says yeah I proved it it
was methane Oh surprise surprise you
know and the other guy who goes through
the see volcanoes he comes they know as
volcanoes you know so they all prove
their foregone conclusions and what do
you learn from these people you know
they don't have a mechanism that really
addresses the only issue an extinction
Theory has to address and
selectivity others mother nature choose
this species and not that one and more
so how does Mother Nature choose
chronologically always in every single
case 100 percent of the cases ok with
dyes are the old species and what
survives are the newest species so you
have this radiation of little tiny
animals that are tied to the new plants
that are radiating and covering the
landscape and muscling out the old
plants and with the old plants go the
old animals the ancient animals have
been around for too long and that were
tied to the previous ecological or the
previous plants and so now you can see
why there is selectivity through food
because you have one food chain and has
nothing to do with the other food chain
ok or these little maybe there's some
overlap there's always some of that but
in general when all these animals die
it's because they depend on these these
sources of food they get used to it over
millions of years they're not going to
switch at the last moment to something
else that's something else for them
those are weeds they don't eat weeds
animals are smarter than that
okay here's the Triassic okay again we
have these weird little animals this
they were like crocodiles but they stood
like higher from the ground and normal
crocodile today and one of the plants
that was popular in those days was
dichroism
there were others like Daniels's and the
Dickey of phylum very hard to pronounce
some of these plants well these were the
plants that covered the landscape this
is what there was to eat so what else
were they gonna eat if this was the only
thing they had to eat I mean there was
no no weed no rice in those days there
were no grasses there were relatively
few cycads and ginkgos that they were
just starting out they were just
expanding
this was a dry hot period in Earth's
history and so these were the plants
that came out and these were the animals
that developed was respect to those
plants this is what they ate and they
ate this for millions of years you know
it's like you eat you eat I don't know
pancakes and maybe chocolate every
morning because that's what you like and
suddenly someone says look I've got some
pine leaves for you would you like to
eat them I don't think you're gonna
switch overnight the pine leaves from
your ice cream in your chocolate in your
pancakes okay and so here it is like
rhodium is an extinct genus of four
cleaved seed ferns that were distributed
over Gondwana during the Triassic
between 52 to 201 million years ago the
flora is dominated by the seed fern dyke
rhodium a Morpho genus that is
widespread and usually dominant in
middle to late triassic plant
assemblages throughout Gondwana yeah
these were popular plants this is what
these animals had to eat they had
nothing else to eat but what you see
there so so there was nothing else to
eat don't don't tell me well you know
maybe they wanted to eat something else
they went at cake instead of ice cream
no no this is all they has and so when
these plants went out what do you think
would happen and these plants did die at
the end of the Triassic so it's like
well you know that doesn't seem like you
need to be a rocket scientist to figure
it out that food has something to do
with those animals and what continued
were the dinosaurs which were tiny
animals that had grown someone in the
past before the these are Co stars
that's what they were called all these
crocodiles like animals they dominated
the landscape they were big and here
were the little dinosaurs in the
background you know running around like
ants like ants are with respect to us
today are like mice or whatever and so
yeah when the arcus r went away the
dinosaurs could now expand and each one
grabbed his own niche you know occupy
their niches and diversified that's what
happened why because now the plants
diversified and you had all these
different types of dinosaurs just you
know
squat some territory and some types of
plants for their own use and you know
right behind the herbivores came the
Predators you know they said oh I like
that animal I'm gonna I'm gonna carve a
niche within that his world okay here's
the Jurassic okay that came next and
again same situation essentially I think
ginkgos were one of the important ones
that disappeared several ginkgos the
only one survived to today which is the
Bulova but there were many types of
ginkgos in those days and all of them
disappeared and our acharya there were
very many types of these trees that
disappeared today we have our oak area
in different parts of the world but the
types of our acharya that these animals
ate probably disappeared and with them
the big dino so the ones who depended on
this source of food and as it says here
fossils are tribute able to genus ginkgo
first appeared in the early Jurassic and
the genus diversified and spread
throughout lower Asia during the middle
Jurassic and early cretaceous it
declined in diversity as the Cretaceous
progressed yeah I think what happened is
that towards the end of the Jurassic a
lot of these plants you know they they
have this big hump where they grow in
diversity and in numbers and then they
begin their decline okay and then they
they don't just chop off and fall to
extinction no it's just gradually fewer
species and fewer numbers the forests
the jungles of some of these plants get
smaller they become smaller islands
smaller islands and the animals are you
know kind of suffering looking for food
and by this time the animals have
suffered something else you know they
probably got used to some of the endemic
diseases they live longer they have they
air they have kids and so they become
numerous as as herds but their food
sources are dwindling underneath their
feet while they are becoming more
numerous what happens at some point
there's a
- lots of them begin to die and the
carnivores that prey upon them they find
the same problem because suddenly you
know they you know as they kill the
herbivores they find trouble finding
food themselves and the last part of
that process is cannibalism you you kill
someone in your own tribe yeah you start
eating the big guy eats little guy sort
of thing you know dog-eat-dog world okay
so what's next well the last segment
here is the Cretaceous and I've covered
this in the past and you can see what
happened there from the end of the
Jurassic 145 million years 0 to 65
million years ago those 80 million years
starting about 130 million years ago the
angiosperms were invented mother nature
Venna DOS and suddenly suddenly what
happens the angiosperms start crowding
out all the other species of plants
especially all the conifers because the
conifers were dominant in the Jurassic
and in the Cretaceous and suddenly the
Cretaceous now the latter half you could
say almost started getting the conifers
that got crowded out by the angiosperms
and for sure you know you can see the
cycads dwindled down to nothing
practically ferns they had a little
spike there but you can see the
diversity decreased tremendously for
ferns as well ginkgos they had
practically disappeared the only one
that continued is again you know the
biloba which we have today and again we
call why do we call it a living fossil
because ginkgo biloba is that's the last
order that remains of this plant it
shows you what happens to these plants
if there were some animal that still
lived on ginkgo you know that Anna would
be dead
practically he'd have a hard time
finding ginkgos out there because you
don't find ginkgo plants on the on the
planet
you know they're not very popular and so
even though they're arguing goes and
some
who would have found them would have
continued living the point here is that
when that whole jungle of ginkgos
collapse a lot of animals went with it
and maybe there were ginkgos on the
other side of the planet it didn't
matter to those animals you know they
they were dead they had no food and so
this is what happens food disappears the
animal disappears very simple mass
extinction there I mean to understand it
okay what the Cretaceous here I put a
little of synopsis there the large
forums died in the seas and what's these
survived were tiny forums that were
coming up and again here you have the
same situation you have the the little
mammals and big dinosaurs that's more or
less the situation there yeah the it's
the big forums the ones that had been
around for a long time they had evolved
to a point where they were giants and
those it was time their time was up
and what continued were the small forums
which were essentially you know had
nothing to do with the old forums these
people these animals took over the that
same niche and at the bottom you see
good old Triceratops and again it's the
ancient species that disappeared what
survived were the new animals there you
see a little rat like animo and you see
a monkey monkey came a lot lot later
okay but the point is what survived were
the mammals why because they were hiding
in the in the ways almost waiting for
the dinosaurs to go away so today you
have this ridiculous notion that a lot
of paleontologists say professionals you
know scientists as they call them and
they say that you know if it weren't for
that lucky asteroid you know the
dinosaurs would still be around we
wouldn't be here unbelievable
no no dinosaurs were guaranteed because
they were big they were not going to
evolve any longer they had they had
reached their maximum extent and we're
more or less in the same boat ok ok and
here's another snapshot of that same
idea you have the Giants were the ones
who disappeared you have the gigantic
Quetzalcoatlus the Massa stars on the in
the waters and the t-rex is on land it's
a big guys that disappeared and they
were all old that's why they were big
because they had millions of years of
evolution to make them bigger they what
is known as cokes law overtime animals
grow bigger and bigger and bigger humans
have done that as well you know we're
the biggest humans that ever lived in
this day and age and what survived again
we're the birds the some of the reptiles
mammals you know those are what survived
okay but primarily what the old species
were the ones that went away and you
know you can't you can't explain that
with an asteroid as through asteroids
are not intelligent enough to
distinguish between the archaic species
and the new up-and-coming you know the
upwardly mobile species okay they don't
have that ability to discern and just in
case you still wondering here we have
good ol Alvarez the Alvarez uh push the
asteroid theory what do they say this is
from their paper okay 1980 seminal paper
because this is where they they got the
idea of the asteroid and today it's it's
the idea pushed by all paleontologists
essentially 40 years now this has in
brief our hypothesis suggests that an
asteroid struck the earth formed an
impact crater and some of the dust sized
material ejected from the crater reached
the stratosphere and was spread around
the globe why because it covered you
need to cover the globe with dust that
stops the sunlight right this dust
effectively prevented sunlight from
reaching the surface for a period of
several years several years that means
plants are gonna die right and as a
result most food chains Kalev chains
collapsed so there you have he he's
saying it's the food chain right and
that's the seminal paper food chain
that's what he's talking about
and and the extinctions resulted so
extinctions resulted from two
food chain collapse now they have to
explain you know why some animals
survive because if if you have this dust
that covers the entire planet and the
plants die for several years what did
the mammals eat what did the other
animals eat you know like in in the
waters and it's like they don't pay
attention to this like they brush over
and say well we got a theory we can't
explain all the e aspect you cannot
explain anything you get if you did not
explain selectivity so so this is an
idiotic theory because it doesn't
explain selectivity that's what should
should be discarded if it can't explain
selectivity I don't care if an asteroid
hit the earth or not it has nothing to
do with the extinction and they haven't
explained the process instead they went
out there and look for evidence you know
all mathematical physics and all this
they they rely on evidence they believe
in evidence so they say let's look for
evidence and sure enough they found a
place in Chicxulub in Mexico the Yucatan
region there and they say hello an
asteroid hit here well first of all I'm
not sure that's an asteroid I'm not
convinced I looked at it doesn't look
like an asteroid in a crater to me
eventually the part unmanned because
there's half of it is in the land half
of it is in the sea and the part that
man doesn't even look like a crater you
look at craters if you look at old
craters they look like craters that one
doesn't look like a crater but they had
to turn it into a crater so that this
theory could have a chance and even if
the theory has a chance because of the
crater
they still haven't explained selectivity
okay so you might say well what does uh
what does all this have to do with the
extinction of man why do we have to go
through all this thumb stuff well again
what I'm saying here is you gotta take
extinction 101 you have to tell me how
the animals in the past died before you
get to man because mother nature's not
so sophisticated she doesn't have
different mechanisms for four different
species and she doesn't have or habitats
for that matter and she doesn't have
a different mechanism for the different
agents she doesn't do volcanoes in the
Permian and asteroids in the in the
Cretaceous especially because none of
them can explain selectivity and none of
them for sure can explain chronological
selectivity that what died were the big
animals why did the big animals die well
because they were already well developed
completely developed and why were they
developed because they developed they
evolved with the plants in which they
carved a niche that's why so what are we
saying I'm saying that if all these
animals died you know if you take the
Carboniferous amphibians they die
because of food Permian they die because
of food Triassic they died because of
food you know starvation their sources
of food ran out dinosaurs
Jurassic dinosaurs Cretaceous also food
sources right now
oh there seems like there's a pattern
there seems like a cookie cutter to me
and so if we apply that to man can man
avoid starvation running out of food
especially went when we produce this
food only because of money because of
our economy for eight billion people I
mean it's very simple I just bring God
with his magic wand I don't care and you
wipe out all the money in the planet
okay all the zeros and the ones run the
computers right
no no bank accounts no money and people
or just wave this magic wand and people
have no faith in money anymore right
whatever the point is if we eliminate
money altogether for whatever reason
today right don't you think that would
affect the production of food the
planning of food the distribution of
food I mean if we don't get a computer
we don't get a car we don't get a or an
airplane boat so what you know here we
had 30 million people unemployed in the
United States nobody nobody suffered you
know you can still go to the store get
food
no problem you you haven't even noticed
other than the fact that you can't go to
restaurant okay so we don't need those
jobs they were unemployed before they
got unemployed but the point here I'm
trying make is you know if if food
disappears if many of this appearance
food disappears therefore disappears
well I can guarantee that you're gonna
die so all I can say is that at least
you know if food disappears that's a
good mechanism for extinction for at
least for your extinction your personal
extinction
you can't live without food so that is
something you should consider
especially when I have people like
Albers also go to the food chain to make
their case so food is something you got
to think about and so here's the
challenge for you homework okay homework
and it's a challenge for anyone who
wants to take over so please listen
carefully okay I don't want you to tell
me why man's not gonna disappear because
of food or because the economy collapses
I want you to do it in Reverse
okay you don't have to believe I want
you to come up with a mechanism let's
assume you wanted to kill man through
starvation just assume that you don't
have to believe in it all you have to do
is make an assumption and say look let's
say I wanted to kill humanity okay your
God here right how would you go about it
short of miracles I mean I you can make
your magic wand move around say all all
food disappears now that's too simple
you need to think a little bit okay you
got to make it difficult on you
I propose money disappears food
disappears the other day we had guy
McPherson I covered his his proposal
which is climate change and then food
disappears he also is a food
disappearing guy but he does it through
climate I did through the economy here's
the ball in your court now you do it
let's assume you wanted to kill man
through starvation through the food
chain okay how would you go about doing
it come up with a mechanism see if you
can invent one see if you can come up
with one okay and hopefully that'll get
your mind working to see you know what
things could be involved in in man's
disappearance
due to food yay so I can say is come up
with a mechanism and you can't use money
because I'm the guy already came up with
that so you can't come up with it again
and we have a mister guy in Macpherson
his buddies and they say it's climate
change okay and so you can't come up
with that one they already came up with
that one so you got to come up with the
third one okay something else how would
you kill man through the food cycle
assuming you wanted to kill man and with
that I'll see you next time hopefully on
Sunday and maybe we'll continue with a
little bit of this will see that bye bye